diese überwachungskamera in thailand
film nichts dramatisches alles wirkt
friedlich eine frau hantiert an ihrer
maschine herum und sieht plötzlich das
weite zum glück
die frau entkommt im letzten moment
ihrem sicheren tod vor ihrem geschäft in
der thailändischen provinz stadt hamburg
knapp 250 kilometer südöstlich von
bangkok fast ein auto unkontrolliert in
das haus hinter der frau
offenbar hört die frau das auto
rechtzeitig auf der straße liegt auf und
bringt sich in sicherheit
sekunden später schlägt der verunglückte
pickup dort ein wo sie eben noch auf
ihrer maschine saß die reaktionsschnelle
frau kann gerade noch weg springen der
aufprall zerstört den pavillon vor dem
haus zwei personen werden verletzt und
kommen ins krankenhaus
die frau mit dem siebten sinn hat
unfassbares glück und kommt mit dem
schrecken davon